Maligayang pagbabalik sa pag-unawa sa quantum na impormasyon at pagkalkula. Ang pangalan ko ay John Watrous at ako ang teknikal na direktor para sa edukasyon sa IBM
Quantum. Ito ang ika-16 at huling aralin ng serye at ang paksa ng aralin ay fault tolerant quantum
computing. Sa kurso ng tatlong nakaraang aralin ay nakakita tayo ng ilang halimbawa ng mga quantum error correcting code na makakakita at nagpapahintulot sa ating
ituwid ang mga quantum na pagkakamali basta hindi masyadong marami ang nangyayari. Kung nais nating gamitin ang pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali para sa quantum computing gayunpaman ay mayroon pa ring maraming
mga isyu na kailangang harapin kasama ang katotohanan na ang ating mga quantum gate, sukat, at state
na paghahanda ay malamang na hindi rin perpekto. Kaya, halimbawa, kung magsasagawa tayo ng pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali sa isa
o higit pang mga qubit na na-encode gamit ang isang quantum error correcting code, kailangan nating gawin iyon gamit ang mga gate at sukat na mismo ay
may pagkakataon na hindi gumana nang tama. At nangangahulugan iyon ng hindi lamang kabiguang matuklas o maituwid ang mga pagkakamali kundi posible rin
na makapagdala ng mga bagong pagkakamali. Bukod pa rito, kailangan din nating isagawa ang mga aktwal na pagkalkula na interesado tayo nang muli gamit ang mga gate na hindi
perpekto. At tiyak na hindi natin maaaring i-decode ang quantum na impormasyon para sa layunin ng pagsasagawa ng mga pagkalkula at pagkatapos
ay i-re-encode kapag tapos na tayo dahil maaaring magtamaan ang mga pagkakamali kapag wala ang proteksyon ng isang quantum error correcting code.
Nangangahulugan iyon na kailangan nating malaman kung paano magsagawa ng mga quantum gate nang direkta sa mga logical qubit na hindi kailanman walang
proteksyon ng isang quantum error correcting code. Ito ay isang mahirap na hamon ngunit alam na hangga't ang antas ng ingay
ay nasa ibaba ng isang tiyak na threshold na halaga, ito ay posible na magsagawa ng arbitrarily na malaking quantum na pagkalkula nang maaasahan gamit ang maingay na hardware, kahit man lang
sa teorya. At tatalakayin natin ang kritikal na mahalagang katotohanang ito sa ibang pagkakataon sa aralin. Narito ang isang maikling pangkalahatang-ideya ng
aralin. Magsisimula tayo sa isang pangunahing modelo para sa fault tolerant quantum computing kasama ang maikling talakayan
ng mga noise model pati na rin ang isang pangkalahatang pamamaraan para sa pagpapatupad ng isang quantum circuit nang fault
tolerant. Pagkatapos ay lilipat tayo sa isyu ng paglaganap ng pagkakamali sa mga fault tolerant quantum circuit at kung paano
kontrolin ito. Sa partikular, tatalakayin ko ang mga transversal gate implementation na nag-aalok ng napaka-simpleng paraan upang kontrolin ang paglaganap ng pagkakamali
bagaman may isang pangunahing limitasyon na pumipigil sa atin na gamitin ang pamamaraang ito
nang eksklusibo. Pag-uusapan ko rin ang isang iba't ibang pamamaraan na kinabibilangan ng tinatawag na mga magic state na nag-aalok ng ibang landas sa pagkontrol ng paglaganap ng pagkakamali
sa mga fault tolerant quantum circuit bagaman hindi ito ang tanging kilalang pamamaraan at sa huli ang aralin
ay nagtatapos sa medyo mataas na antas ng talakayan ng threshold theorem na binalaan ko kamakailan.
Ang teoremang ito ay nagsasabing ang mga arbitrarily na malaking quantum circuit ay maaaring maipatupad nang maaasahan basta ang error rate ng lahat ng mga sangkap
na kasangkot ay bumaba sa ibaba ng isang tiyak na finite na threshold na halaga. Sa pangkalahatan, ang threshold na halagang ito
ay depende sa error correcting code na ginagamit natin pati na rin ang mga tiyak na pagpipilian na ginagawa natin para sa mga fault tolerant na implementasyon ng
mga quantum gate at sukat ngunit hindi sa laki ng circuit na ipinapatupad. At nagbibigay ito sa atin ng magandang dahilan upang maniwala na ang malawak na
quantum na pagkalkula ay isang araw ay magiging katotohanan. Magsisimula tayo sa pamamagitan ng pagtalakay ng isang pangunahing modelo para sa fault tolerant quantum
computing na natural na nakabatay sa mga quantum circuit at quantum error correcting code. Para sa layunin ng talakayan na ito
ay isipin natin na mayroon tayong isang quantum circuit na umaasa nating maipatupad tulad ng ipinapakita dito. Nagkataong ito ay
isang teleportation circuit kasama ang paghahanda ng EBIT. Ngunit ang mga detalye ay hindi talaga mahalaga para sa talakayan na ito. At maaari mong isipin na
ito ay anumang iba pang quantum circuit, posibleng mas malaking circuit na kinabibilangan ng mga paghahanda ng estado, unitary
na mga operasyon, at mga sukat. Ang circuit na ito, siyempre, ay kumakatawan sa isang ideal at isang aktwal
na implementasyon nito ay hindi magiging perpekto. Ang natural na tanong na itatanong ay ano ang maaaring magkamali
Napakaraming maaaring magkamali. Halimbawa, ang mga pagsisimula ng estado ay karaniwang hindi
perpekto. Siyempre, ang mga unitary gate ay hindi magiging perpekto at ganoon din ang mga
sukat. At bukod pa rito, ang mga qubit mismo ay magiging madaling kapitan ng ingay kasama ang decoherence sa bawat punto sa
pagkalkula kahit na walang nangyayari sa mga qubit na ito at simpleng nag-iimbak lamang sila ng quantum na impormasyon. Sa ibang salita, halos lahat
ay maaaring magkamali. Mayroon isang pagbubukod gayunpaman o kahit man lang iyon ay isang tipikal na pagpapalagay at
iyon ay ang anumang klasikal na pagkalkula na kasangkot ay malamang na hindi magiging may depekto dahil para sa lahat ng intensyon at
layunin ang mga klasikal na pagkalkula ay halos perpekto. Kaya halimbawa, kung nagpapatakbo tayo ng klasikal na matching algorithm upang
kalkulahin ang mga pagtutuwid para sa mga surface code na pagkakamali, hindi talaga natin kailangang mag-alala na ang klasikal na pagkalkulang ito ay maaaring may depekto. Ngunit ang anumang direkta
na kinabibilangan ng quantum na impormasyon ay maaaring. Siyempre, kailangan natin ng tumpak na modelo kung saan maaari nating iugnay
ang mga probabilidad para sa iba't ibang bagay na magkamali. At kung gusto natin ay maaari tayong gumawa ng kasing kumplikadong modelo tulad ng gusto natin upang sana ay maipakita ang kahit anong
talagang nangyayari sa katotohanan. Kung masyadong kumplikado ang modelo gayunpaman ay maaaring maging mahirap o imposible ang pagtrabaho nito o sabihin ang
anumang kawili-wiling bagay tungkol dito. Isang napaka-simpleng halimbawa ng isang noise model na madalas isinasaalang-alang ng mga tao
ay ang independent stochastic noise model kung saan ang mga pagkakamali o depekto na nakakaapekto sa iba't ibang sangkap sa iba't ibang
sandali o sa ibang salita, iba't ibang lokasyon sa circuit ay hiwalay.
Halimbawa, maaari nating sabihin na ang bawat gate ay nabibigo nang may tiyak na probabilidad, na ang mga bit flip at phase flip ay nangyayari sa mga nakaimbak na qubit nang may ibang
probabilidad bawat yunit ng oras at iba pa. Ngunit ang pagpapalagay ay walang ugnayan sa pagitan ng iba't ibang
pagkakamali. Ngayon, maaaring tumutol ka sa modelong iyon dahil malamang ay may ilang ugnayan sa pagitan ng
mga pagkakamali. Halimbawa, malamang may maliit na pagkakataon ng isang catastrophic na pagkakamali na nag-aalis ng lahat ng qubit nang sabay.
O marahil mas malamang, maaaring may mga pagkakamaling naka-localize ngunit nakakaapekto pa rin sa maraming sangkap.
At walang nagmumungkahi ng iba. Ngunit gayunpaman, ang modelong ito ay kumakatawan sa isang simpleng baseline na
sa esensya ay kumakatawan sa ideya na ang kalikasan ay hindi mahuhulaan ngunit hindi ito malisyoso at hindi ito sinusubukang sadyang
sirain ang mga quantum na pagkalkula. Mayroong iba pang posibleng mas makatotohanang mga noise model na madalas isinasaalang-alang. At anuman ang
modelo na ating pipiliin, kung lumalabas na ang ating modelo ay nagdala sa atin sa maling daan at natututo tayo ng bago tungkol sa mga pagkakamali sa
kahit anong sistema na ating ginagamit, ay natural nating maihahanda at isasaalang-alang ang iba't ibang mga error model. Susunod, ay titingnan
natin ang isang pangunahing estratehiya para sa pagpapatupad ng mga quantum circuit nang fault tolerant. Kaya isaalang-alang natin ang isang partikular na
logical quantum circuit, ibig sabihin ang isang ideal na quantum circuit na interesado tayong patakbuhin. Halimbawa, maaari nating isaalang-alang ang katulad na circuit tulad ng
dati, na ngayon ay medyo napalawak nang kaunti dahil kailangan natin ng kaunti pang espasyo para sa fault tolerant na implementasyon nito. Una
sa lahat, ang mga paghahanda ng estado, unitary gate, at mga sukat ay hindi isasagawa nang direkta bilang mga single gate o bilang mga
single qubit na sukat o mga paghahanda ng estado kundi isasagawa sila ng mga tinatawag na gadget na
maaaring bawat isa ay kinabibilangan ng maraming qubit at maraming operasyon. Dito sa diagram na ito ay
inilalarawan ko ito sa pamamagitan ng paglalagay ng mga purple na kahon sa paligid ng mga bagay na ito. At maaari mong isipin ang mga purple na kahon na ito bilang parang mga maliit na circuit o operasyon na
nilabel lamang ng kahit anong paghahanda ng estado o gate na nilayon naming ipatupad. Pangalawa, kailangan nating protektahan
ang mga qubit gamit ang isang error correcting code. Kaya hindi ang mga logical qubit mismo ang magkokonekta sa iba't ibang mga gadget kundi ang mga gadget ay kumikilos sa
mga pisikal na qubit na nag-e-encode sa mga logical qubit na ito. At sulit na bigyang-diin dito na ang mga logical qubit na pinakamahalaga sa atin
ay hindi kailanman nalantad, ibig sabihin ang mga logical qubit na ito ay gagugol ng kanilang buong buhay na protektado ng kahit anong
quantum error correcting code na ginagamit natin. At sa huli, nagsasagawa tayo ng pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali sa ating mga naka-encode na qubit
nang paulit-ulit sa buong pagkalkula, halos tuwing may pagkakataon tayo. At napakahalaga na gawin natin
ito. Sa madaling salita, habang nagaganap ang mga pagkakamali, ang randomness o kawalan ng katiyakan ay nagsisimulang mag-ipon sa estado ng ating
mga qubit at kailangan nating patuloy na magtrabaho upang alisin ang randomness o entropy na ito. At nangyayari ito sa pamamagitan ng pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali.
Kaya maaari mong isipin ang mga hakbang sa pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali na ito bilang parang mga maliit na logical refrigerator o heat pump na
nagpapahintulot sa mga logical qubit na manatiling malamig upang ang pagkalkula ay gumana nang tama.
Kapag nagawa na ang lahat ng pagpipiliang ito, ibig sabihin ang pagpili ng lahat ng gadget pati na rin ng code at iniaasang may partikular na noise model, mayroon
isang pangunahing tanong na maaari nating itanong sa ating sarili at iyon ay, talagang nakakatulong ba ito. Nagpapabuti ba tayo ng mga bagay o
nagpapalala ba tayo ng mga bagay? Kung masyadong maraming ingay, maaaring napaka-maganda ay pinapalala natin ang mga bagay
tulad ng ang 9 qubit Shore code ay nagpapalala ng mga bagay kung ang pagkakataon ng isang pagkakamali ay masyadong mataas.
Ngunit kung ang ingay ay nasa ibaba ng isang tiyak na threshold, ang lahat ng karagdagang trabahong ito ay makakarating sa isang lugar. At tulad ng tatalakayin natin sa katapusan ng aralin,
bubukas ang mga landas para sa karagdagang pagbabawas ng pagkakamali. Sa bahaging ito ng aralin ay tatalakayin natin ang paglaganap ng pagkakamali sa fault
tolerant quantum circuit na may pangunahing istruktura na naibigay ko kamakailan. Nagiging pangunahing alalahanin ito dahil
kung hindi natin mapamamahalaan ang paglaganap ng pagkakamali, ang mga pagkakamali ay mabilis na malulunod ang ating
mga pagsisikap sa pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali. Ngunit kung magagawa nating kontrolin ang paglaganap ng mga pagkakamali, ang ating code ay may mas magandang pagkakataon
na makasabay upang ang mga pagkakamali ay maituwid sa sapat na mataas na rate upang payagan ang ating mga pagkalkula na
gumana. Ang panimula para sa talakayan na ito ay ang pagkilala na ang dalawang qubit gate o mas maraming qubit gate nang mas
pangkalahatan ay maaaring magpakalat ng mga pagkakamali kahit na gumagana sila nang tama.
Halimbawa, isaalang-alang ang isang C NOT gate. At ipagpalagay na ang isang X na pagkakamali ay nangyayari sa control qubit bago ang C NOT gate
ay isasagawa. Ang isang X na pagkakamali ay gumagana tulad ng isang X gate. At natuklasan natin na
ang circuit sa kaliwa ay katumbas ng isa sa kanan kung saan ang mga X na pagkakamali ay nangyayari sa parehong qubit pagkatapos ng C
NOT. Ito ay isang paglaganap ng mga pagkakamali dahil ang kaawa-awang lokasyon ng X na pagkakamali sa kaliwa ay epektibong ginagawa itong
dalawang X na pagkakamali sa kanan. At hindi natin ito malalampasan. Hangga't gumagamit tayo ng C NOT gate, palaging may
pagkakataon na ang isang X na pagkakamali ay nangyayari sa control qubit bago ito, na pagkatapos ay lumaganap sa dalawang X na pagkakamali
pagkatapos. Ngunit tulad ng makikita natin, basta magsagawa tayo ng mga hakbang upang limitahan ang pinsalang dulot nito, ay magiging maayos tayo. At sa pamamagitan ng paraan
katulad na phenomenon ang nangyayari kapag mayroon tayong Z na pagkakamali sa target qubit nang eksakto bago ang C NOT. At tinalakay natin ito
kanina at maaari mong tingnan ang mga pagkakatumbas na ito sa pamamagitan ng simpleng pagsasagawa ng mga multiplikasyon o maaari mo rin itong tingnan gamit ang
Qiskit. Ang mahalagang punto ay sa parehong kaso ay magdudulot ito ng correlated na mga pagkakamali sa maraming qubit. At siyempre ay
hindi dapat nating kalimutan na ang mga C NOT gate mismo ay maaari ring may depekto na maaari ring magdulot ng correlated
na mga pagkakamali. Nagdaragdag sa ating alalahanin, ang mga kasunod na dalawang qubit gate ay maaaring maglalayo pa ng mga pagkakamaling ito.
Halimbawa, kung mayroon tayong tatlong C NOT gate tulad nito, tulad ng makikita natin kapag sinusukat natin ang mga X stabilizer generator, halimbawa, ang isang pagkakamali ay maaaring
mabilis na lumago sa maraming qubit. At kung mangyari ito sa loob ng isang code block, halimbawa, ibig sabihin ang isang grupo ng
mga qubit na magkasamang nag-e-encode ng isang logical qubit, kahit anong error correcting code ang ating pinili ay hindi
magkakaroon ng pagkakataon dahil ang mga code ay idinisenyo upang ituwid ang mga mababang timbang na pagkakamali hindi ang mga mataas na timbang na pagkakamali tulad nito.
At kaya ito ay isang bagay na kailangan nating nasa harap at gitna ng isipan natin sa katunayan habang iniisip natin ang mga gadget at ang
mga hakbang sa pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali sa mga fault tolerant quantum circuit. Ang pinakasimpleng kilalang paraan upang mapaligtas ang paglaganap ng pagkakamali sa fault
tolerant quantum circuit ay ang magpatupad ng mga gate nang transversal at ipapaliwanag ko ang ibig sabihin nito
sa lalong madaling panahon. Kaya panatilihin natin ang figure ng ating fault tolerant circuit implementation sa screen bilang visual na tulong.
Ang ideya dito ay para sa ilang quantum error correcting code, ang ilang gate ay maaaring ipatupad nang transversal na
nangangahulugang ipatupad ang mga ito gamit ang mga gadget na mga tensor product ng mga operasyon kung saan ang bawat operasyon ay kumikilos lamang sa isang
single qubit na posisyon sa loob ng bawat code block. Pinakamadaling ipaliwanag ito sa pamamagitan ng mga halimbawa. Ang una at
posibleng pinakasimpleng halimbawa ay mga transversal na implementasyon ng mga Pauli gate.
Ang ideya ay gusto naming bumuo ng mga gadget para sa bawat isa sa mga gate sa ating circuit. At sa lahat ng kaso ang mga gadget na iyon
ay kumikilos sa mga code block tulad ng makikita natin para sa mga X at Z gate sa katapusan ng ating teleportation circuit. Siyempre ay
hindi natin maaaring i-decode, mag-apply ng Pauli gate, at pagkatapos ay i-re-encode dahil mag-iiwan iyon ng isang logical qubit na hindi protektado at maaaring
lumago ang mga pagkakamali sa loob ng code block bilang resulta ng re-encoding.
Sa kabutihang palad, hindi natin kailangang gawin iyon basta gumagamit tayo ng stabilizer code dahil ang bawat stabilizer code ay nagpapahintulot ng mga Pauli
na operasyon na direktang mailapat sa ating mga logical qubit. At sa katunayan, maaari nating gawin iyon gamit ang isang tensor product ng mga Pauli gate
sa mga pisikal na qubit na ginagamit para sa encoding.
Halimbawa, kung isasaalang-alang natin ang 3x3 surface code na lumabas sa katapusan ng nakaraang aralin, maaari nating ipatupad ang mga X at Z gate sa logical
qubit na ine-encode ng code na ito sa pamamagitan ng pagsasama-sama ng mga X at Z gate kasama ang mga identity gate sa mga pattern na
iminumungkahi dito. Ito ay isang transversal na implementasyon ng mga gate na ito dahil ang bawat isa sa mga indibidwal na gate na
operasyon ay kumikilos lamang sa isang single qubit na posisyon sa loob ng bawat code block.
Gumagamit lamang tayo ng mga single qubit gate dito kaya ito ay medyo simpleng bagay sa isang paraan ngunit sa anumang kaso ang mga gadget tulad nito ay hindi magdudulot ng paglaganap ng mga pagkakamali
Ngayon, ang alinman sa mga indibidwal na gate sa isang gadget tulad nito ay maaaring mabigo at magdadala iyon ng
mga pagkakamali ngunit palagi nating isasagawa ang pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali kaagad pagkatapos ng bawat gadget. At basta ang error rate ay
sapat na mababa, ang error correcting code ay maitatuwid ang mga pagkakamaling iyon.
At tulad ng sinabi ko, ito ay palaging posible para sa mga Pauli gate para sa bawat stabilizer code.
Bagaman kailangan mong tukuyin ang tamang pattern ng mga Pauli gate sa mga gadget upang wastong ipatupad ang kahit anong logical Pauli na operasyon na
hinahanap mo. Para sa isa pang halimbawa na kinabibilangan nga ng dalawang qubit gate. Sa pagkakataong ito ay maaari nating isaalang-alang ang mga transversal na implementasyon
ng mga C NOT gate. Sa partikular, para sa bawat CSS code, palagi nating maipapatupad ang isang C NOT gate
sa pagitan ng dalawang logical qubit sa pamamagitan lamang ng pagsasagawa ng mga C NOT gate sa mga kaukulang pares ng pisikal
na qubit. At natutugunan nito ang kondisyon ng pagiging transversal dahil ang bawat isa sa mga indibidwal na C NOT gate ay kumikilos lamang
sa isang single qubit na posisyon sa loob ng bawat code block. Halimbawa, ang unang C NOT gate ay kumikilos lamang sa pinaka-tuktok na qubit
sa loob ng bawat code block. Ang ikalawang C NOT gate ay kumikilos lamang sa pangalawa mula sa tuktok na qubit at ganoon
din. Sa kasong ito, maaaring may paglaganap ng mga pagkakamali dahil ang mga C NOT gate ay nagpapakalat ng mga pagkakamali at walang
paraan upang maiwasan iyon. Ngunit ang susi ay ang paglaganap ng pagkakamali ay hindi kailanman nangyayari sa loob ng isang code block. Halimbawa
ang isang X na pagkakamali ay maaaring mangyari sa tuktok na qubit ng nangungunang code block nang eksakto bago isagawa ang gadget at ang unang C NOT
sa loob ng gadget ay magpapakalat ng pagkakamaling iyon sa tuktok na qubit sa mas mababang bloke. Ngunit ang dalawang nagresultang pagkakamali ay
ngayon ay nasa magkakahiwalay na mga code block. Kaya ang mga hakbang sa pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali na nagaganap pagkatapos ng gadget ay makakatuwid ng mga pagkakamaling iyon nang hiwalay dahil ang mga
pagkakamaling iyon ay nakakaapekto lamang sa isang qubit sa loob ng bawat code block.
Sa kabaligtaran, kung ang paglaganap ng pagkakamali ay nangyari sa loob ng katulad na code block, maaaring may problema tayo dahil ang
paglaganap ng pagkakamali ay ginagawang mas mataas na timbang na pagkakamali ang mababang timbang na pagkakamali na maaaring hindi mahawakan ng ating code.
Ang implementasyong ito ay hindi gumagana para sa mga hindi-CSS code ngunit basta gumagamit tayo ng CSS code, palagi nating maipapatupad ang mga C NOT
gate nang transversal sa ganitong paraan. At para sa isa pang halimbawa, ang bawat
Clifford gate ay maaaring maipatupad nang transversal para sa Steane code. At sa katunayan para sa anumang color code na isa sa mga talagang magandang bagay tungkol sa mga color
code. Sa partikular ang isang Hadamard gate sa isang logical qubit ay maaaring ipatupad sa pamamagitan ng pagsasagawa ng mga Hadamard gate nang hiwalay sa
bawat isa sa mga pisikal na qubit at ang isang logical S gate ay maaaring ipatupad hindi sa pamamagitan ng isang S gate sa bawat qubit kundi sa pamamagitan ng isang
S dagger gate sa bawat pisikal na qubit. Kaya ang mahalagang punto ay ang mga transversal gate implementation ay inherente na
fault tolerant dahil hindi sila kailanman nagpapakalat ng mga pagkakamali sa loob ng isang code block na nagbibigay sa mga hakbang sa pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali ng isang pagkakataon na maituwid
ang anumang mga pagkakamaling ipinakilala o ipinalaganap ng mga gate na ginagamit para sa mga gadget na ito. Kaya iyon ay maganda at ito ay isang
napaka-simpleng paraan upang bumuo ng mga fault tolerant na gadget at mayroon iba't ibang code na nagpapahintulot ng mga transversal na implementasyon ng iba't ibang gate tulad
ng mga T gate ngunit sa kasamaang palad ay imposible para sa anumang hindi-trivial na code na maipatupad ang isang
universal na set ng mga gate nang transversal na isang katotohanan na kilala bilang Eastin-Knill theorem. Sa mas teknikal na mga termino ang sinasabi nito
ay habang ang ating code ay may distansya na kahit dalawa, ang hanay ng mga gate na maaaring ipatupad nang transversal ay kinakailangang bumuo ng isang
discrete na hanay ng mga operasyon hanggang sa isang global phase at samakatuwid ang hanay na ito ay hindi universal dahil ang mga universal gate
set ay kinakailangang bumuo ng walang hanggang maraming operasyon. Hindi ko ipaliliwanag ang patunay ng teoremang ito na gumagamit ng ilang
pangunahing katotohanan tungkol sa mga Lie group at Lie algebra na hindi mga kinakailangan para sa serye na ito. Ngunit ang pangunahing ideya ay
na ang walang hanggang pamilya ng mga transversal na operasyon ay hindi maaaring mapanatili tayo sa loob ng code space dahil ang mga napaka-maliliit
na pagkakaiba sa mga transversal na operasyon ay mahusay na maaaring ilarawan ng mga mababang timbang na Pauli na operasyon na tinutuklas ng code bilang
mga pagkakamali. Kaya masaya tayo kapag maipatupad natin ang mga gate nang transversal. Ngunit para sa kahit anong code na pipiliin natin, alam nating palagi nating
magkakaroon ng ilang gate na hindi natin magagawang ipatupad sa ganitong paraan. At kaya kailangan nating maghanap ng mga alternatibong gadget. Dahil sa
Eastin-Knill theorem, alam natin na hindi posible na maipatupad ang isang universal na set ng quantum gate nang transversal kahit man lang
para sa isang mababang distansya 2 quantum error correcting code. Kaya kailangan nating makahanap ng iba pang paraan upang maipatupad ang mga gate nang fault
tolerant kahit man lang para sa ilang gate. Isang kilalang paraan upang gawin ito ay sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng tinatawag na mga magic
state. Para sa layunin ng talakayan na ito, alalahanin natin ang mga S at T gate na
mga single qubit gate na tinukoy tulad ng ipinapakita dito sa screen. Pansinin din natin na una ang S ay isang Clifford na operasyon
na sumusunod mula sa ating kahulugan ng mga Clifford na operasyon. Ngunit maaari mo ring tingnan na ang pag-conjugate ng isang Pauli matrix ng S ay palaging nagbibigay sa atin ng plus o minus ng isa pang
Pauli matrix. At pangalawa, ang T ay hindi isang Clifford na operasyon. At sa katunayan, kung pagsasamahin natin ang T sa Hadamard at C NOT, parehong
Clifford na operasyon, makakakuha tayo ng universal na set ng quantum gate. Kaya hindi natin maipapatupad ang isang T gate
gamit lamang ang mga Clifford na operasyon at standard basis na sukat nang mag-isa. Ngunit maaari nating ipatupad ang isang T gate gamit ang
mga Clifford na operasyon at standard basis na sukat kung bukod pa rito ay mayroon tayong isang kopya ng estado na ipinapakita dito sa
screen, na siyang T gate na inilapat sa isang plus state.
Ang estado na ito ay tinatawag na magic state, bagaman hindi ito natatangi sa pagpapalagay na iyon.
Ang terminong magic state ay ginagamit din upang tumukoy sa iba't ibang estado na gumaganap ng katulad na papel sa estado na ito sa mga pagbabago ng buong
scheme na ito. Halimbawa, ang circuit na ipinapakita dito ay gumagawa ng trabaho. At hindi masyadong mahirap tingnan
iyon. Narito ang paunang estado na may nangungunang sistema sa kanan. At kung i-apply natin ang C NOT gate at pasimplehin, makukuha natin ang
estado na ipinapakita dito.
Kaya kung susukat tayo ng ibabang qubit at makakakuha ng zero na nangyayari nang may probabilidad na 1/2, hindi tayo magsasagawa ng
S gate at ang output ay T na inilapat sa |ψ⟩.
At kung susukat nating isa na nangyayari rin nang may probabilidad na 1/2 siyempre ay i-apply natin ang S gate at ang net na resulta ay
muli ang output ay T na inilapat sa |ψ⟩. Hindi ito ang tanging paraan upang gawin ito sa pamamagitan ng paraan. Mayroon iba pang katulad na mga circuit na
gumaganap ng katulad na gawain ngunit isa itong paraan upang gawin ito.
Ito ay isang medyo pinasimpleng halimbawa ng isang bagay na kilala bilang quantum gate teleportation, na binalaan ko noong aralin 4, kung saan ginagamit ang teleportation upang
hindi magpadala ng mga qubit kundi mag-apply ng mga gate. Ang koneksyon sa teleportation ay maaaring hindi ganap na malinaw dito dahil tulad ng
sinabi ko, ito ay isang pinasimpleng bersyon, na maaari nating maging kasangkapan dahil ang T ay diagonal. Ngunit kung interesado ka sa
pag-aaral ng higit pa, ang mga keyword ay quantum gate teleportation.
At maaari rin tayong gumawa ng katulad na bagay upang ipatupad ang isang S gate kung saan sa pagkakataong ito ang mga gate lamang na kailangan natin ay isang C NOT gate at isang Z gate kasama ang sukat
na kapaki-pakinabang kung wala tayong transversal na implementasyon ng isang S gate. Kaya iyon ay kawili-wili ngunit hindi
ganap na malinaw na talagang nakakatulong ito. Sa kaso ng T gate na implementasyon, halimbawa, ay
nagtagumpay tayong mag-apply ng T gate sa isang input state. Ngunit para gawin iyon ay mukhang nag-a-apply tayo ng T gate sa isang plus state upang makakuha ng isang
magic state. At ang sitwasyon ay katulad para sa S gate na implementasyon. Ang punto ay hindi natin
kinakailangang lumikha muna ng isang plus state at pagkatapos ay mag-apply ng T gate upang makakuha ng magic state. Mayroon iba pang posibleng paraan upang makuha ang estadong ito. At sa
partikular, maaari nating gawin ito nang hindi na kailangang mag-alala tungkol sa pagpapakalat ng mga pagkakamali sa kahit anong pagkalkula na ating ginagawa dahil ang mga magic state ay maaaring likhain
nang hiwalay. Nagpapahintulot ito para sa isang fault tolerant na implementasyon ng isang T gate tulad ng maikling ilalarawan ko ngayon.
Una, hindi talaga tayo magpapatakbo ng simpleng dalawang qubit circuit na ipinapakita dito, kundi sa halip ay magpapatakbo tayo ng circuit na ito gamit ang
mga qubit na naka-encode sa kahit anong error correcting code na ginagamit natin para sa ating fault tolerant na implementasyon. Nangangahulugan iyon na ang
mga unitary gate at ang mga sukat ay ginagawa ng mga fault tolerant na gadget. At nangangahulugan din iyon na kailangan ang ating mga
magic state na ma-encode rin. Kaya lahat ay magiging fault tolerant basta makuha natin ang mga naka-encode na magic state.
Inaakala natin dito sa pamamagitan ng paraan na mayroon na tayong fault tolerant na gadget para sa isang S gate. Kung
gagamit tayo ng Steane code halimbawa ay maaari nating ipatupad ang S gate nang transversal. At para sa mga code kung saan hindi iyon gumagana, isang opsyon ay
gamitin muna ang buong scheme na ito upang ipatupad ang isang S gate nang fault tolerant at pagkatapos gamitin ang implementasyong iyon dito.
Bagaman hindi iyon ang tanging opsyon. Ngunit sa anumang paraan, bumabalik sa implementasyon, ang mahalagang tanong na natitira ay kung paano makukuha natin ang ating mga kamay
sa isang naka-encode na magic state dahil wala pa tayong fault tolerant na implementasyon ng isang T gate upang maging simple iyon
Ang pangunahing ideya ay maaari tayong gumamit ng probabilistik na proseso upang lumikha ng mga naka-encode na magic state. At kung hindi
ito magtagumpay, ayos lang iyon. Maaari nating itapon ang anumang mga nabigong pagtatangka at subukan muli.
At hindi iyon gumagambala sa pagkalkula na talagang sinusubukan nating isagawa dahil ang paglikha ng mga magic state ay ginagawa
nang hiwalay. Isang tipikal na paraan na ginagawa ito ay sa pamamagitan ng isang proseso na kilala bilang magic state distillation. At gumagana ito tulad ng
sumusunod. Mayroon tayong isang tiyak na circuit na kilala bilang distiller. Isinasalud natin sa distiller na ito ang isang koleksyon ng maingay na magic
state at pagkatapos ay sinusukat natin ang lahat maliban sa isa sa mga output. At kung tayo ay naka-kondisyon na ang lahat ng mga resulta ng sukat ay zero,
ang nangyayari ay ang lalabas ay isang mas hindi maingay na magic state, na maaaring maging isa sa mga qubit na isinapalad sa
isa pang distiller. At ang proseso ay nagpapatuloy hanggang sa mabigo tayo dahil ang isa sa mga resulta ng sukat ay hindi zero at susubukan natin muli o mayroon na tayong magic
state na sapat na mataas ang kalidad na ligtas na maaari nating gamitin upang ipatupad ang isang T gate sa pagkalkulang pinakamahalaga sa atin.
Mayroon iba't ibang kilalang paraan upang bumuo ng isang distiller tulad nito ngunit lahat sila ay gumagana sa halos katulad na paraan, na ang mga ito ay mga decoder para sa mga stabilizer code,
ibig sabihin ang mga inverse ng mga encoding circuit, na maganda dahil nangangahulugan iyon na ang distiller ay maaaring maging isang Clifford
na operasyon. At sa huli, ang proseso ng distillation na ito ay talagang nagaganap sa logical qubit na antas. Kaya sa katotohanan, ito ay
lahat ay ginagawa gamit ang mga gadget para sa distiller at ang mga sukat. Ang prosesong ito ay kailangan
na magsimula sa isang lugar. Ngunit basta ang rate ng ingay ay hindi masyadong mataas, posible na lumikha ng maingay ngunit sapat na magandang
mga magic state upang simulan ito. Halimbawa, sa pamamagitan ng pag-apply ng aktwal na maingay na T gate sa isang qubit sa isang plus state at pagkatapos
ay pag-encode ng qubit na iyon. Kaya iyon ay isang napaka-mataas na antas na paglalarawan ngunit sana ay nabigyan kita ng magaspang na ideya kung paano ito gumagana.
Ito ay mas kumplikado kaysa sa pagpapatupad ng mga gate nang transversal ngunit gayunpaman nag-aalok ito ng paraan upang maipatupad ang isang universal na set ng quantum
gate nang fault tolerant, samantalang ang mga transversal gate implementation nang mag-isa ay hindi kayang gawin iyon. Minsan ay inaangkin
na ang overhead para sa paggamit ng mga magic state upang maipatupad ang mga gate nang fault tolerant sa mga linya na ito ay magiging napaka-mataas
kung saan ang napakalaking bahagi ng trabaho ay pumupunta sa pag-distill ng mga magic state at ang pagpapatakbo ng aktwal na pagkalkula ay mas parang isang
karagdagang bagay. Ngunit hindi iyon masyadong malinaw at nagkaroon ng mga detalyadong pagsusuri na nagpapakita na ang pamamaraang ito
ay maaaring sa katunayan ay praktikal. Mayroong ilang iba pang kilalang scheme para sa pagpapatupad ng mga gate nang fault tolerant. Ang code deformation at code switching ay mga pangalan
na nauugnay sa ilang mga scheme na ito at patuloy na binubuo at pinahuhusay ang mga bagong paraan ngunit hindi ko ilalarawan ang mga
pamamaraang iyon sa araling ito. Mayroon isa pang mahalagang isyu tungkol sa mga fault tolerant na implementasyon ng mga quantum circuit at
ito ay tungkol sa mga hakbang sa pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali mismo. Kaya hindi ito tungkol sa pagpapatupad ng mga gate. Ito ay tungkol sa paggawa ng
aktwal na pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali. Ang problema ay kung iisipin natin ang mga simpleng circuit na una nating
nakita sa aralin 14 para sa pagsukat ng mga stabilizer generator batay sa phase estimation, natuklasan natin na sila ay hindi
mismo fault tolerant dahil maaari nilang posibleng idulot ang paglaganap ng mga pagkakamali sa loob ng isang code block.
Ito ay bumabalik sa ideya na ang anumang kinabibilangan ng quantum na impormasyon ay madaling kapitan ng mga pagkakamali at kasama doon ang mga circuit na mismo ay nilalayong
magwasto ng mga pagkakamali. Ito ay mukhang medyo napaka-problematiko ngunit mayroon sa katunayan maraming kilalang solusyon sa problemang ito. Banggitin ko lang ang ilang
sa kanila bagaman hindi ko ipapaliwanag ang alinman sa mga ito nang detalyado. At sa pamamagitan ng paraan, kung naiisip mo na ang fault tolerant quantum computing ay
kumplikado at maraming detalye na kailangang pag-alalahanin, iyon ay tiyak na maiintindihan dahil totoo iyon. Maraming gumagalaw na bahagi
dito at ang layunin ko sa araling ito ay hindi ipaliwanag ang lahat ng detalye kundi bigyan ka lamang ng pangunahing panimula kung paano lahat ito
gumagana. Isang pamamaraan para sa fault tolerant quantum error correction ay kilala bilang Shore error correction na pinangalanan pagkatapos ni Peter
Shore na unang nagmungkahi ng pamamaraang ito. Ang ideya ay isagawa ang bawat syndrome measurement gamit ang isang tinatawag na cat state
na katulad ng isang GHZ state kapag mayroon tayong tatlong qubit ngunit maaari itong i-generalize sa anumang bilang ng qubit na tumutugma sa timbang ng stabilizer
generator na nilayon naming sukatin. Sa partikular, ang circuit na ipinapakita dito ay gumagana para sa pagsukat ng isang stabilizer generator. At maaaring
maipaliwanag na ang pamamaraang ito ay hindi nagdudulot ng paglaganap ng mga pagkakamali sa loob ng isang code block.
Kinakailangan nitong lumikha ng cat state mismo. At upang gumana nang maaasahan sa harap ng mga pagkakamali at posibleng may depektong mga gate, ang pamamaraan ay talagang
nangangailangan na paulit-ulit tayong nagpapatakbo ng mga circuit tulad nito at gumagawa ng mga inferensya tungkol sa kung saan ang iba't ibang pagkakamali ay maaaring naganap sa panahon ng
proseso. Isang alternatibong pamamaraan ay kilala bilang Steane error correction na unang iminungkahi ni Andrew Steane at ang
pamamaraang ito ay gumagana nang naiiba at gumagana lamang ito para sa mga CSS code. Sa pamamaraang ito, hindi tayo nagsasagawa ng mga syndrome measurement sa mga naka-encode na quantum
na estado sa circuit na sinusubukan naming patakbuhin kundi sa halip ay sadya nating pinapakalat ang mga pagkakamali sa isang workspace system
at pagkatapos ay sinusukat natin ang sistemang iyon at klasikal na tinutuklas ang mga pagkakamali. Ang figure na ipinapakita dito ay nagpapakita kung paano gawin ito para sa mga X na pagkakamali kung saan ang workspace
mga qubit ay unang nakatakda sa isang encoding ng isang plus state. Kaya ito ay mahalagang isang
transversal na implementasyon ng isang C NOT gate na dapat walang gawin dahil ang target ay nasa isang plus state. Ngunit kung mayroon
mga X na pagkakamali sa mga tuktok na qubit, lalago ang mga ito pababa sa mas mababang sistema at matatuklas ang mga ito. Mayroon din katulad na pamamaraan para sa pagtuklas ng mga Z na pagkakamali
at hindi iyon ipinapakita dito. Mayroon din katulad na pamamaraan na kilala bilang Knill error correction na unang iminungkahi ni Manny Knill
at batay ito sa teleportation kaysa sa isang transversal C NOT at nagpapahintulot ito sa pagtatrabaho para sa arbitrary na stabilizer
code at hindi lamang para sa mga CSS code.
Ang huling bagay na tatalakayin ko sa araling ito ay isang napaka-mahalagang teorema na kilala bilang threshold theorem. Narito ang medyo impormal na
pahayag ng teorema. Sinasabi nito na kung mayroon tayong anumang quantum circuit na may n gate kung saan ang n ay maaaring kasing laki ng gusto natin, ay
posible na ipatupad ang circuit na iyon nang may mataas na katumpakan gamit ang isang maingay na quantum circuit basta ang antas ng ingay
ay nasa ibaba ng isang tiyak na threshold na halaga na hiwalay sa n. At bukod pa rito, hindi ito masyadong mahal upang gawin ito sa
kahulugang ang laki ng maingay na circuit na kinakailangan ay nasa order ng n beses ng ilang pare-parehong kapangyarihan ng logarithm ng
n. Upang sabihin ang teorema nang mas pormal ay kinakailangang maging tiyak tungkol sa noise model, na hindi ko gagawin sa araling ito.
Maaari itong halimbawa na mapatunayan para sa independent stochastic noise model na binanggit ko kanina kung saan ang mga pagkakamali ay nangyayari
nang hiwalay sa bawat posibleng lokasyon sa circuit nang may ilang probabilidad na mas mahigpit na mas maliit kaysa sa threshold na halagang ito. Ngunit maaari rin itong
mapatunayan para sa mas pangkalahatang mga noise model kung saan maaaring may mga ugnayan sa pagitan ng mga pagkakamali. Ngayon, ito ay isang teoretikal
na resulta at ang tipikal na paraan na ito ay napapatunayan ay hindi kinakailangang isalin sa isang bagay na talagang gagawin natin sa pagsasanay ngunit ito ay gayunpaman isang napaka-
mahalagang teorema sa praktikal na mga termino. At ang dahilan para dito ay mahalagang sinasabi nito na walang pundamental na hadlang sa pagsasagawa ng
mga quantum na pagkalkula gamit ang maingay na mga sangkap.
Basta ang error rate para sa mga sangkap na ito ay nasa ibaba ng threshold na halagang ito, maaari silang gamitin upang bumuo ng maaasahang mga quantum circuit ng arbitrary
na laki. Isa pang paraan upang sabihin ito ay kung ang teorema ay hindi totoo, mahirap isipin ang malawak na quantum computing na
magiging katotohanan. Maraming teknikal na detalye ang kasangkot sa mga pormal na patunay ng teoremang ito, na hindi ko susubukang
iparating. Ngunit susubukan kong ipaliwanag ang pangunahing ideya sa mataas na antas. At susubukan ko rin na maluwag na iugnay ang pangunahing
ideya sa kung ano ang inaasahan nating mangyayari sa pagsasanay. Kaya ipagpalagay na ito ang ating circuit. Ito ang katulad na circuit na
pinag-usapan natin sa buong aralin. Ngunit muli, maaari nating isipin na ang ating circuit ay mas malaki at mas kumplikado kaysa dito. Gusto naming
ipatupad ang circuit na ito ngunit lahat ng ating mga sangkap ay maingay. At inaakalang gumagamit tayo ng independent stochastic noise
model lamang para sa pagiging simple, mayroon ilang probabilidad P kung saan ang mga pagkakamali ay nangyayari nang hiwalay sa bawat posibleng lokasyon.
Kung ang circuit ay mas malaki kaysa sa reciprocal ng probabilidad P na ito, ay halos tiyak na ang isang
direktang implementasyon nito ay hindi gagana nang tama. Kaya dinadaan natin ang lahat ng gawain ng pagpapatupad ng circuit
nang fault tolerant tulad ng tinalakay ko hanggang sa puntong ito sa aralin at itatanong natin ang sarili natin ang tanong na itinayo ko kanina na kung gagawin natin ang mga bagay
nang mas mabuti o nagpapalala ba tayo ng mga bagay? Kung ang probabilidad P na kumakatawan sa error probability para sa bawat isa sa ating mga sangkap ay masyadong malaki ay
hindi ito makakatulong tulad ng ang 9 qubit Shore code ay hindi nakakatulong kung ang error probability ay mas mataas sa 3 at 3/4% o higit pa.
Sa partikular, pinalaki na natin ngayon ang circuit. Kaya maraming pang lokasyon kung saan maaaring magtamaan ang mga pagkakamali.
Gayunpaman, kung ang P ay sapat na maliit, makakatulong ito. At ang epektibong gagawin natin ay bawasan ang error
probability para sa logical na pagkalkula na ating isinasagawa. Kaya pag-isipan natin ito nang
kaunti pang detalye. At upang makita ang mga pangunahing ideya sa pinakasimpleng posibleng setting, ipagpalagay nating ginagamit natin ang 7 qubit Steane code para sa pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali
na nagpapahintulot ng pagtutuwid ng hanggang isang pagkakamali bawat code block. Kaya upang may isang logical na pagkakamali
na mangyari sa orihinal na circuit, ay kailangan nating magkaroon ng kahit dalawang pagkakamali na nahuhulog sa katulad na code block para sa ating fault
tolerant na implementasyon.
Isinaisip na mayroon maraming iba't ibang paraan upang magkaroon ng dalawa o higit pang mga pagkakamali sa katulad na code block, maaaring matwirang sabihin na ang probabilidad ng isang logical
na pagkakamali sa bawat lokasyon sa orihinal na circuit ay pinakamaraming C * P^2 kung saan ang C ay isang bilang na nakasalalay sa code at sa
mga gadget na ginagamit natin. Ngunit kritikal, hindi ito nakasalalay sa laki ng orihinal na circuit.
Kaya kung ang P ay mas maliit kaysa sa reciprocal ng C na siyang bilang na maaari nating gawin bilang ating threshold na halaga ay
nagsasalin ito sa isang pagbaba sa pagkakamali. Kaya ang ating pagsisikap sa pagpapatupad ng circuit nang fault tolerant ay nagbubunga
Gayunpaman ang bagong error rate na ito ay maaaring masyadong mataas pa para sa buong circuit na gumana nang tama. Kaya kailangan nating gumawa pa
ng higit pa. Sa pagsasanay ang natural na bagay na gagawin sa puntong ito ay pumili ng mas magandang code at mas magandang mga gadget upang mapababa ang error
rate sa isang punto kung saan ang implementasyon ay malamang na gumana.
Sa teoretikal na pagsasalita, isang simpleng paraan upang matwirang sabihin na ito ay posible ay ang i-concatenate. Sa ibang salita iniisip
natin ang fault tolerant na implementasyon ng orihinal na circuit bilang isang bagong logical circuit. At pagkatapos ay ipinapatupad natin ito nang fault
tolerant. At pagkatapos ay ginagawa natin ito muli at muli nang kasing dami ng beses na kailangan natin. At lumalabas na binabawasan nito ang pagkakamali
nang napakabilis. At iyon ang paraan ng tipikal na pagpapatunay ng threshold theorem sa papel.
Bibigyan kita ng napaka-magaspang na ideya kung paano bumababa ang error rate na iniiwan ang maraming teknikal na detalye na kinakailangan upang
gawing pormal ito. Nagsisimula tayo sa error probability P para sa ating orihinal na mga sangkap. At kung ipapatupad natin ang
circuit nang fault tolerant, ang pagkakamali ay bumababa ng isang factor na C * P. Kung pagkatapos ay tratuhin natin ang ating fault tolerant
na implementasyon bilang isang logical circuit at ipatupad ito nang fault tolerant, makakakuha tayo ng katulad na pagbaba sa error rate. Ngunit
kung iisipin natin ang epektibong error rate para sa orihinal na circuit, natuklasan nating mas lalo itong bumababa dahil ngayon
ay pinapalitan natin ang error rate P ng C * P^2 dahil iyon ang epektibong error rate pagkatapos ng unang antas ng fault
tolerant na implementasyon. Partikular, pagkatapos ng kaunting algebra, natuklasan natin na ang pagkakamali ay bumaba sa (CP)^3 * P. At kung
gagawin natin ito muli, mayroon na tayong error rate na (CP)^7 * P. At kung
patuloy nating gawin ito para sa kabuuang K na antas, ang natuklasan natin ay ang pagkakamali ay doble-exponential na lumiit sa K. Kaya hindi
natin kailangang gawin ito nang maraming beses upang maging napaka-maliit ang error rate.
Samantala, ang mga circuit ay lumalaki ngunit ang laki ay isa lamang na exponential ang pagtaas sa K dahil sa bawat
antas ng fault tolerance, ang laki ng ating circuit ay lumalaki ng pinakamaraming isang factor na tinutukoy ng pinakamataas na laki ng
ating mga gadget. At kapag pinagsama-sama at ginawa ang angkop na pagpili para sa bilang
ng mga antas ng concatenation, makukuha natin ang threshold theorem. Ngunit tulad ng iminungkahi ko na, maraming detalye ang kinakailangan upang gawing pormal ito. Kaya
ano ang threshold na halagang ito sa katotohanan? Nakasalalay ito sa code at sa mga gadget na
ginagamit natin. Para sa Steane code kasama ang magic state distillation ito ay napaka-liit at malamang na hindi makakamit sa
pagsasanay. Ngunit gamit ang mga surface code at mga pinakabagong gadget, tinantiya itong nasa humigit-kumulang 1%. Na hindi
masama. At habang natutuklasan ang mga bagong code at pamamaraan, makatwirang inaasahan natin na ito ay tataas habang sabay-sabay na ang
antas ng ingay sa mga sangkap na ating ginagawa ay bababa. Ang pag-abot sa puntong kung saan
ang malawak na quantum na pagkalkula ay maaaring ipatupad nang fault tolerant ay hindi magiging madali at hindi ito magaganap nang magdamag.
Ngunit ang teoremang ito kasama ang mga pagsulong sa mga quantum code at sa quantum hardware na nasaksi natin hanggang ngayon
ay nagbibigay sa atin ng optimismo na kailangan natin upang magpatuloy sa pagsulong upang maabot ang pinakamataas na layuning ito ng pagtatayo ng isang
malawak na fault tolerant quantum computer. At iyon ang katapusan ng aralin at ang katapusan ng serye. Talagang
umaasa akong natuklasan mong may halaga ang serye at kung oo, pakiisaalang-alang ang pagrereklamo nito sa isang katrabaho o kaibigan.
Tiyakin din na tingnan ang IBM Quantum Learning para sa karagdagang mga kurso at tutorial at mag-subscribe sa Qiskit
YouTube channel kung hindi ka pa nag-subscribe upang manatiling updated sa aming mga paparating na nilalaman. Salamat sa
panonood.